salut les épicurieuses et les epicurieux
ça vous dirait de faire rimer vacances
et sciences alors c'est parti pour mon
top 5 des lieux scientifiques à visiter
cet été
1 la chaîne des puits nul besoin d'aller
au bout du monde pour admirer de
superbes volcans la chaîne des puits en
Auvergne en compte 80 sur près de 32 km
ce sont des volcans monogéniques cela
signifie qu'ils se sont formés à
l'occasion d'une seule et unique
éruption la plus récente a eu lieu il y
a 8500 ans les hommes en ont été témoins
les volcanologues n'exclut pas la
possibilité que certains d'entre eux se
réveillent un beau matin mais je vous
rassure ils sont sous haute surveillance
le plus emblématique de tous c'est le
Puy-de-Dôme il culmine à 1465 mètres
d'altitude là haut la vue est imprenable
sur la chaîne depuis un petit accéder à
pied par deux chemins de randonnée qui
ont été aménagés à cet effet le sentier
des muletiers et le chemin des chèvres
les moins courageuses se contenteront
d'embarquer à bord du panoramique des
dômes c'est un petit train touristique
qui offre une vue à 360 degrés lors de
la montée je l'ai pris c'est magnifique
tirez à ce propos nous avons réalisé une
vidéo sur la chaîne depuis elle est ici
avec un peu de chance l'élève tôt
pourront observer au sommet du
Puy-de-Dôme son spectre de Broken c'est
un phénomène physique assez surprenant
lorsque le soleil n'est pas encore levé
sur l'horizon l'ombre de la montagne se
projette sur les nuages si cette ombre
n'est pas trop éloigné on peut voir sa
propre silhouette dans le brouillard
avec plusieurs auréoles colorées un
spectacle bien mérité après une bonne
randonnée matinale
de la grotte Chauvet après avoir tutoyé
les cimes plongeon 25 mètres sous terre
du côté de Vallon-Pont-d'Arc en Ardèche
c'est ici que Jean-Marie Chauvet a
découvert une étonnante grotte
souterraine en 1994 il en est donc
l'inventeur et oui c'est le nom que l'on
donne au petit chanceux qui découvre une
grotte et le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que Jean-Marie Chauvet a fait une
sacrée trouvaille comme Lascaux sa
grotte est ornée de peinture mais ce qui
la rend unique au monde c'est qu'à
laquelle elles ont été réalisées il y a
plus de 30000 ans durant une période
appelée aux rignacia au départ cette
estimation réalisée au carbone 14 à
déconcerté de nombreux spécialistes en
effet jamais des peintures rupestres
aussi anciennes n'avaient été mis au
jour à titre de comparaison le bestiaire
de Lascaux ne date que de 18000 ans les
dessins de Chauvet n'ont rien à envier
au chef-d'oeuvre de sa petite sœur ces
parois sont couvertes de lion de chevaux
de rhinocéros et de mammouth la plupart
de ces dessins ont été réalisés à
locreux rouge c'est le tout premier
pigment utilisé par l'homme pour peindre
d'autres ont été composées à l'aide de
charbon de bois l'ancêtre du fusain que
nous utilisons aujourd'hui
malheureusement la grotte Chauvet en
tant que telle n'est plus accessible au
public suite à une série d'éboulements
mais sur le modèle de Lascaux ça
réplique à l'identique a été construite
juste à côté c'est la plus grande
réplique de grotte au monde
le triangle noir du Quercy après avoir
goûté à l'obscurité des grottes on n'est
pas fâché de revoir le ciel et bien
justement parlons-en du ciel direction
un petit coin de France où il est si pur
qu'il permet d'observer les étoiles
comme nulle part ailleurs lorsqu'on 2002
une carte de la qualité des ciels
nocturnes en France et publiés un
triangle noir apparaît au dessus du parc
régional du Quercy c'est la zone de plus
faible pollution lumineuse de France
métropolitaine elle se situe entre
Rocamadour et la vallée du séléni la
pureté du ciel y rendu possible grâce à
l'action des habitants des 39 communes
aux alentours il s'astreignent à
éteindre les feux autour de minuit
résultat dans ce sanctuaire céleste la
lumière nocturne est entièrement
naturelle elle laisse apparaître des
étoiles qui sont invisibles ailleurs
c'est le cas du bulbe de la Voie Lactée
cette région du ciel est très riche en
étoiles en nébuleuse et en poussière
d'étoiles le spectacle est à couper le
souffle pour en faire profiter le plus
grand nombre le parc du Quercy a ouvert
plusieurs sites d'observation et si vous
êtes novice en astronomie pas de panique
des clubs du coin organisent des sorties
pédagogiques à la nuit tombée pour
observer les étoiles ce qui s'y rendre
en famille ou entre amis trouveront
alors disposition des logements équipés
de télescopes histoire d'admirer le ciel
depuis sa fenêtre tellement romantique
non 4 la dune du Pilat non nous ne
sommes pas au Sahara mais en
nouvelle-aquitaine à l'entrée du bassin
d'Arcachon entre l'océan Atlantique et
une gigantesque ferait de pain trône la
majestueuse d'une du Pilat c'est la dune
de sable la plus haute d'Europe elle
culmine actuellement un peu plus de 100
mètres et s'étale sur presque 3 km de
long et plus de 600 mètres de large sa
taille varie au fil du temps en fonction
du vent et de l'érosion mais comment
cette montagne de sable est-elle arrivée
là entre forêt et océan
en réalité cette merveille géologique ne
s'est pas formée en un jour c'est le
fruit d'un long processus qui a débuté
il y a plus de 4000 ans son histoire est
liée à la formation d'un banc de sable
le bande à rien il est situé au large à
15 minutes de la dune en bateau au fil
des siècles les courants marins ont
déplacé du sable on dit qu'ils l'ont
charrier pour former ce banc c'est
vandouest en provenance du large arrache
à sa surface des grains de sable au
moment de la marée basse quand il est
totalement à découvert ces grains de
sable sans volent alors pour se poser
sur la dune et former ce gigantesque tas
de sable la Dune est impressionnante par
sa taille mais aussi par l'époustouflant
panorama qu'elle offre depuis son sommet
sur le Bassin d'Arcachon le phare du Cap
Ferret et la forêt à perte de vue mais
pour profiter du paysage il faut
atteindre le sommet les plus vaillants
effectuent la montée les pieds dans le
sable bon courage la pente est de 30 à
40 degrés les autres utilisent
l'escalier qui est installé chaque année
au printemps petit rappel le sable de la
dune reste sur la lune 5 pour clôturer
notre périple des meilleurs sites
scientifiques direction le LHC large à
John leader plus communément appelé en
français accélérateur de particules il
se trouve à la frontière franco-suisse
entre Genève et le pays de Gex c'est là
à 100 mètres sous terre que se trouve le
plus grand et le plus puissant
accélérateur de particules au monde
inauguré en 2008 puis arrêter en
décembre 2018 il reprend du service
cette année et la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'on peut le visiter ce monstre de
technologie se présente sous la forme
d'un tunnel de presque 27 km de
circonférence presque la moitié de la
ville de Paris à l'intérieur on fait
tourner des particules à des vitesses
vertigineuses ce sont des protons ils
ont la particularité d'être composé de
particules encore plus petites comme le
fameux boson de Higgs il s'agit d'une
particules de matière que les
scientifiques avaient prédites par
calcul en 1964 le boson est resté
théorique jusqu'en 2012 année où le LHC
a annoncé l'avoir enfin détecté
l'événement a fait la une dans le monde
entier pour obtenir ce type de
particules le LHC provoque une collision
d'une extrême violence entre deux
protons ils sont propulsés à une vitesse
qui frôle celle de la lumière autrement
dit un peu moins de 300000 km par
seconde en une seule seconde justement
nos protons font tenez-vous bien 11000
fois le tour du tunnel ça donne le
tourne puis ils sont projetés l'un
contre l'autre pour être désagrégée en
analyse ensuite les débris qui en
résulte en repoussant encore les limites
le LHC nous permettra peut-être de
prouver l'existence de la matière noire
qui composerait à elle seule 27% de
l'univers on suppose ça n'existence mais
à ce jour on a toujours pas détecté
alors je vous rassure ne vous décomposez
pas la visite du LHC ne prévoit pas un
tour de tunnel à la vitesse de la
lumière merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo jusqu'au bout c'est vraiment le
meilleur soutien que vous pouvez
apporter à la chaîne si vous avez pensé
à d'autres lieux qui mériteraient leur
place dans ce top n'hésitez pas à les
mettre en commentaire ça en intéressera
plus d'un mois le premier je vous
souhaite à toutes et à tous
d'excellentes vacances mais avant de
partir n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à
très bientôt les épicurieuses et les
épicuriens